so now we will discuss how to penalize
insertions and deletions in sequence
alignment and more sophisticated way
previously we use native scoring for in
DOS where we assigned fixed penalty
Sigma to each endo however this fixed
penalty isn't good to represent series
of hundreds of consecutive indels and we
will call this sequence of K consecutive
indels is single evolutionary event gap
rather than mult
many evolutionary events of small
insertions and deletions to model this
situation in sequence alignment
algorithms will use affine gap penalty
where we use two constants one is Sigma
which is gap hopping penalty and the
second one is epsilon which is gap
extension penalty and usually Sigma is
more than episode since starting gap
should be penalized more than extending
it and a formula to calculate analogy
for a gap of length K will be Sigma plus
epsilon times K minus 1 so let's take a
look now how we can use this in our
Manhattan grid previously we had a
single edges with weight Sigma to
represent insertions and deletions and
these edges were horizontal and vertical
edges in our Manhattan grid now we can
add more edges for example we can add an
edge of a weight Sigma plus epsilon
which will represent a gap a single gap
of length 2 and for our Manhattan grid
we actually need to add a lot of this
address so we need to add a separate
edge for all gaps of likes two edges for
all gaps of thanks three and more and
more and we will need to edit vertically
and horizontally how many edges have we
added to our graph actually we edit
edges proportionally to
and cube where n is the length of
sequences which we are trying to compare
since sequence alignment algorithms
runtime is proportional to the number of
edges our algorithm will be quite slow
it will run proportional to the n cube
how we can improve this ranked time of
algorithm we can split our Manhattan
grid into three levels bottom level
middle level and upper level bottom
level will represent insertions and will
contain only edges which goes vertically
from node to node middle level will
represent matches and mismatches and
will contain diagonal edges upper level
will represent deletions and will
contain only horizontal edges of our
graph and still we need to find a path
between top left corner to the bottom
right corner and we can move in our
Manhattan grid but we also can move
between these layers of the grid so for
example we can take one edge diagonally
and now if we want to make insertion we
need to move to the bottom level take
one edge there and move back to the
middle level and this two edges will
represent a single gap with Sigma as a
gap opening penalty and Epsilon as a gap
extension penalty after that we can
continue moving on the middle level for
example we found a match between our
sequences and then if you want to
represent deletion we need to move to
upper level make some movements there
and go back to the middle level and we
can finish our path to model this
mathematically we can have a three
different equations for dynamic
programming for each level and lower
level
we'll use information from lower level
itself and a middle level middle level
we'll use information from all three
levels and upper level we'll use
information from upper level itself and
the middle level how many edges does
this three level Manhattan grid have
hint is a degree of which note is quite
small so each node in this three layered
Manhattan will have only one two or
three neighbors and number of edges is
proportional to the n square so the
runtime of this algorithm will be the
same as before but currently we can use
more sophisticated affine gap penalty
than the native penalty which we used
before